los equipos de rescate avanzan entre
aguas turbias en busca de desaparecidos
la región norteña italiana de Emilio
romaña ha sido golpeada por Fuertes
lluvias en días recientes estas han
causado deslizamientos y resultaron en
la evacuación de miles de residentes 24
y 24 municipalidades se han inundado
desafortunadamente todos los ríos de
Emilia romaña se han desbordado por
encima de sus cotas causando
inundaciones
en la región han sido descritas como
apocalípticas y sin precedentes incluso
han llevado a las autoridades a cancelar
el gran premio de Emilia romaña de
Fórmula 1 debido a Preocupaciones en
torno a la seguridad Los residentes
afectados tratan de salvar lo que pueden
todos vivimos en la planta baja por allá
ha sido una tragedia porque estamos
tomando lo que podemos salvar que es muy
poco mínimo los niños no entienden nada
sólo están llorando
no creí que llegaría hasta aquí
las fuertes inundaciones en Emilia
romaña han dejado miles de hogares sin
electricidad la región ya había sido
golpeada por intensas lluvias hace dos
semanas la primera ministra italiana por
su parte prometió apoyo a los afectados
y dijo que su gobierno estaba listo para
intervenir con ayuda